Yes. I just have a question the "smorgasbord" religiosity thing you described. Yep. I want to suggest that it may have more integrity than you.
Did I dismiss it?
Okay okay.
No.
Only, only because. All you smorgasbordly religious, my
apologies.
Only because I, I think there are historical currents in particular religious traditions that give rise to that kind of approach to religiosity, forms of Buddhism certainly, forms of Hinduism, where, you know, you can wander in a street in Punjab, India, and walk into a Hindu household and you have a picture of baby Krishna next to a picture of Mother Mary and you ask, you know, what is this, you know, don't they contradict, and there is no contradiction. There is a sort of orientation to religion that allows one to collect gems in ways that do underlie a particular worldview and support it. So, and I, I, I kind of, I like that in the United States because I think it's promising if everyone is going to evolve and learn how to co-exist peaceful. I want to, I want to argue that it doesn't necessarily threaten the sort of a, a, a religion's own self-identity.
Yeah, no, I think, it's a, it's a good point. And
question also is how, how does one distinguish, say, between syncretistic modes of
religiosity with
relatively stable forms of syncretistic modes of religiosity, which
have been there in many places in the world for very long periods
of time
from
relatively fast-paced, changing modes of religiosity of picking and choosing
and crafting and kind of bricolage
religiosity
as one goes, goes along, right. That's, that's one, one distinction.
The other distinction, I, I, I think you're, you're many ways, in many, way, ways right that the, it can have a
certainly positive values and certainly it reduces tensions between religions and that's a,
that's a plus of smoragsbord religiosity.
The possible minus might be, depending where, from where you look
is that, that generally they become
a, a very much individualistic
and they do work
for the individual.
Way I sometimes describe various functions of religions, I don't know whether I mentioned,
I, I, I think I mentioned this, in this class.
They, they tend to be,
they, they tend to be then either performance-enhancing drugs religions.
You need to
achieve something, right,
and then you need spiritual
energy
to do that, right,
or they tend to be what I call band-aid religions.
So you, you kind of walk through life, you get bruised
here and there and then you, you, you need a bit, bit of help
or a kind of,
of
local wisdom for, for action,
but they, they don't,
tend not to
give you accounts of, of reality.
They tend not to form robust enough communities
in order to, to, to resist
anything and to introduce social change.
They, they kind of, you float with them and that may be what some people might like and may
be exactly what,
what's right,
but from other perspective, that may be
a real detriment because you, you can't,
you can't create social movement for change
with these type of religiosities, right.
So, it's pluses and minuses. Sorry if I was too
maybe dismissive of it.